last year titanfall 2 in battlefield one
made up the main course of my shooter
diet but sometimes you gotta branch out
get away from the old chicken and
mashers try that section of the menu
that you kind of hate but it's good for
you it won't kill you right we'll judge
it ain't kidding me I am of course
talking about survival shooters and they
will kill you a lot here are 3 i've been
playing lately that you should consider
number one h1z1 king of the kill this
game has an interesting history it
started as the battle royale mod for
arma 2 and 3 before making its way over
to the faltering survival game h1z1 it
was then realized as a much more
successful version of that core game and
broken off a standalone king of the kill
has some great ideas for one players get
to parachute in at the start letting
them get the lay of the land and where
other players are going then deciding if
they want to land in a city for
immediate gunfights or play the long
game stay away from other players in
order to give themselves the best chance
of being the last one standing after all
only one person or team can survive the
map starts at its full size and pushes
players closer and closer together as
they scavenge craft and kill one another
it's still a game in development and I'd
love to see some changes like vehicles
not being such a guaranteed ticket to
the end game as well as a greater
variety of weapons and ability to craft
weapon mods but it has all the tension
in front of a daisy survival style game
without requiring that huge time
investment into each life a fun loot
crate system lets players look
ridiculous at the risk of being easy to
spot number to escape from tarkov this
game is still in early alpha stages but
we did get our hands on a build and like
the potential this game has it's a
tactical scavenge and survive style
shooter at this stage the game has one
large but channeled level customs one
medium-sized interior warehouse map
called Factory and one open map called
woods it supports both PvP and PvE modes
an expensive weapon customization system
is set against the gamble of losing all
your gear that you take with you into
each PvP round the game revolves around
scavenging weapons in parts and then
escaping the level with them did
helpers are also saying that tarkov has
plenty of Secrets to find players can
buy keys and go looking if they want to
risk it we're keeping an eye on the real
money paid for inventory sizes in this
game especially with pre-orders being
priced from 4499 to 130 999 but this
game has potential as a survival shooter
and we'll keep you posted as it develops
number three the Division survival DLC
the divisions realistic environment
screams survival at every turn but in
the end collecting all those water
bottles and canned beans and walnut
beanies didn't really amount to much the
latest survival DLC fixes many of those
problems by starting players with
nothing and making them fight the
elements viruses and NPCs or other
players to craft and battle for limited
resources until they die or get
extracted from the dark zone a virus
clock counting down to the players in
pending microbial doom keeps the pace of
each match intense all the players are
rewarded with high level gear based more
on milestones like time survived number
of things crafted and kills rather than
necessarily making it out alive survival
gives players a glimpse of a game that
could have been but more importantly
it's a hell of a lot more fun than the
core experience and those are three
survival games you can consider to round
out your shooter lifestyle if you like
shooter survival games like we do give
us that like or subscribe and we'll make
more of these videos for you thanks for
watching
you